[Musique]
et nous accueillons jour un regret
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sénateur des vosges du groupe union
centriste au sénat vous étiez jusqu'à
votre élection le maire de la commune de
remiremont
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous d'être
venu des vosges ce matin bercy pour vous
interroger à mes côtés alexandre
poplavski mayor bonjour alexandre jours
merci d'être là directeur départemental
de vosges matin on commence évidemment
par la crise sanitaire jean regrets
quelle est la situation dans les vosges
actuellement mais pour l'instant nous
avons 3200 doses par jour
seulement il faudra bientôt deux ans
pour vacciner la totalité des vosges
donc la situation est vraiment difficile
à nous attendons un signal fort de la
part du gouvernement pour amener
naturellement plus de doses et vaccinés
les vosgiens
oui on fait des taxes vous estimez que
l'approvisionnement ne répond pas aux
attentes de la population
non je vois par exemple centre
hospitalier de remiremont dont je suis
toujours membre du conseil de
surveillance
nous sommes entre 800 et 1000 doses par
jour alors qu'on nous en avait promis 5
à 6 fois plus et donc franchement la
situation s'aggrave de jour en jour
jean castex à a pris la parole hier
pas de confinement pas d'interdiction de
déplacement entre les régions pas
d'accentuation du couvre-feu est ce qu
il a pris les bonnes décisions pour vous
est-ce qu'il faut désormais des mesures
plus strictes après vous savez c'est
facile de commenter mais difficile
d'agir je pense que le gouvernement est
dans une situation dramatique on n'a pas
forcément toutes les données mois jusque
je regrette en tant que parlementaire
c'est le fait que le gouvernement
n'associe pas plus l'assemblée nationale
et le sénat dans ses décisions c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai voté contre
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
je pense qu'on doit faire face à ses
responsabilités que le gouvernement
devra associer les parlementaires mais
aussi les collectivités territoriales
davantage
il avait été question un moment que jean
castex viennent de voir le devant le
parlement débat avec vote encadrent
confinement est ce que vous dites ce
débat se voit-il doit quand même avoir
lieu même si a pas de décision de
confinement oui il faut associer plus
mais vous savez il ya quand même un
problème c'est que quand par exemple
olivier ferrand vient au sénat on a on
en sait moins à la fin de son
intervention qu'à son arrivée donc au
bout d'un moment faudrait nous le dire
les choses
je pense que les français sont prêts à
entendre des choses et arrêter de nous
prendre pour des imbéciles
c'est ce qu'il fait pour vous il prend
les parlementaires pour dézinguer tout
albert mauvais oui on nous prend pour
des imbéciles
alexandre comment ça se traduit c'est à
dire que le fait qu'ils viennent et qui
vous répondent pas aux questions ou kiki
les buts certains points font que oui je
pense qu'il faut être dans un discours
de vérité par exemple le prochain invité
jean rottner je pense que le président
haute mer a toujours un discours de
vérité
je pense que les politiques devraient
prendre leur courage à deux mains et
dire la vérité aux français je pense que
nous sommes capables d'entendre la
vérité et faire face le discours de
lancement de manière collective cette
ascèse pandémie le discours de vérité
c'est de ne par confiner vous pensé
quand même que c'est une bonne mesure où
pas de ne par confiner mais après on n'a
pas les chiffres c'est difficile de se
prononcer moi j'ai pas les différends
politiques nous n'avons pas les chiffres
si on avait les différents éléments
pourraient se prononcer et
au niveau du parlement de manière
collective prendre des décisions on va
parler d'une décision qui est vous
impact dans les vosges c'est celle de ne
pas ouvrir les remontées mécaniques oui
évidemment dans le massif des vosges on
est suspendu à cette attente visiblement
donc il y aura pas de remonter encore au
mois de février est ce que vous avez
vous des remontées à la fois du monde
hôtelier de la restauration est
évidemment de toutes ces structures qui
accueillent du public pendant les
périodes de vacances qui débutent ce
samedi à la colère ne cesse d'augmenter
au fur et à mesure que les semaines
s'écoulent c'est pour ça que nous avions
une délégation parlementaire emmenée par
mon collègue cédric vial de savoie dont
je faisais partie pour alerter président
de la république sur différentes
difficultés dont il n'avait pas
forcément entre guillemets les
informations comme parlant des
difficultés au niveau des emplois
saisonniers
hier le premier ministre nous a envoyé
une lettre avec différentes mesures qui
ont été prises pour moi ce ne sont
encore que des mesurettes je pense qu'il
faut aller plus loin
concernant les saisonniers le droit à la
formation va être repris en totalité par
l'état
mais je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin
faut des mesures plus fortes la
situation est vraiment grave
vous sentez vraiment qu'il ya des des
entreprises qui sont qui sont à la
limite il ya déjà eu beaucoup de
suicides dans les vosges le niveau de
chefs d'entreprises de patrons
d'établissements de culturelle des bars
des restaurants donc je pense que la
situation est dramatique
photo gouvernement ni des êtres sur la
table un plan de 4 milliard pour la
montagne c'est pas suffisant pour vous
non mais le problème c'est pas n'est pas
là c'est qu'il faut faire du sur mesure
je pense que il ya des grandes aides qui
sont donnés mais il faut faire confiance
aux collectivités territoriales je pense
que ça soit les champs de la région mais
aussi du département
on doit faire du sur mesure et aider
des gens qui qui passent à travers les
dispositifs et donc il faut les aider
davantage et que le préfet et les élus
que nous sommes puissent faire du sur
mesure à aider des gens qui sont passés
à travers les mailles du filet vous
encouragez quand même les français à
venir en vacances pendant les vacances
qui débutent
je n'encourage rien du tout chacun prend
ses décisions en son âme et conscience
si les gens veulent découvrir les rouges
ils ont bien raison puisque c'est un
très beau département et justement on va
y rester dans les vosges on va parler à
transversale exemple oui c'est
évidemment le les transports et
notamment le tgv est un outil de
désenclavement pour pour ce territoire
votre christian poncelet qui était quand
même une figure tutélaire pour les
rouges s'étaient battus pour pousser de
la vigne qui allait de jusqu'à paris
nancy epinal jusqu à remiremont est ce
qu est ce que pour vous cette ligne a
toujours une pérennité ou alors allez
menacées par un nouveau plan de la sncf
tgv empruntent cette ligne tgv
qu'elle aille jusqu'à saint dié jusqu'à
armement epinal elle est indispensable
cette ligne tgv puisque que ce soit pour
le tourisme mais aussi pour les chefs
d'entreprise vont les différentes
personnes qui l'utilisent elle a montré
son efficacité au cours des dix
dernières années je pense qu'il est
important et nous avons entendu une
petite petite musique un petit bruit il
ya quelques mois avec mes collègues
parlementaires les élus de la région et
nous sommes intervenus je pense que
c'est important que de manière
collective en défendent aussi nos acquis
et que la sncf ne décide pas tout seul
ils ont quand même réduit le nombre
d'arrêts la mois d'arrêt par jour sur la
ligne e points à 2 allers-retours par
jour pour l'instant remiremont
elle est sauvée elle est menacée non
pour l'instant tout va bien et on est
très attentif il ya quand même cette
musique de fond qui est toujours là oui
mais parce qu'on est dans une période de
restrictions budgétaires et que
naturellement ils veulent réduire la
voilure à certains niveaux mais je ne
veux pas que non plus que les
contribuables et les usagers que nous
sommes payés
les élus lorrains se bat aussi pour que
l'on maintienne en fait mais c'est nous
qui l'avons payé de toute façon manqué
au bout d'un moment
et puis pour la pousser aussi pour
permettre la liaison entre nancy et lyon
est aussi oui mais cela j'espère que je
le verrai un jour allez on va parler de
la collectivité européenne d'alsace
alors évidemment on a entendu il ya
quelques instants sur ce plateau
l'intervention de jean castex est sûr
sûr sûr la communauté européenne
d'alsace
sa légitimité est ce que par rapport aux
représenter le territoire des vosges est
ce que cette intervention a suscité des
inquiétudes par rapport à son
intervention mais au moment de
l'intervention oui après madame goro a
entre guillemets recadrer les choses et
a redonné un autre un autre son de
cloche entre guillemets je précise juste
que devant le sénat lors des questions
d'actualité à l'exil a alors répondu que
thorgal et qui aurait pas de remise en
cause je l'aurais pas de remise en cause
de la grande région je pense que c'est
une bonne chose après tout le monde a pu
être à un moment ou un autre
interrogé sur le périmètre de la région
grand test lors de sa création
mais quand on voit l'efficacité de cette
région que ce soit au niveau de la
pandémie aussi des dispositifs
économiques qui sont mis en place de
toute façon il ya un élément il ya dix
jours et un sondage qui est sorti que ce
soit sur la côte de popularité du
président rod nerfs mais aussi sur ce
que ressentent les habitants de cette
région au niveau de l'efficacité des
dispositifs mis en place on est quand
même dans les régions où la cote de
popularité est dans les sondages nous
sommes les plus haut en termes
d'efficacité donc je pense que la région
grand est a prouvé son efficacité
le périmètre est ce qu'il est je pense
qu'il faut aller de l'avant et ne pas
toujours remettre en cause ce qui a été
fait mais commander vous je vous l'avais
perçu vous cette déclaration de jean
caceres à titre personnel je pense que
c'est une tentative de déstabilisation
politique
après ce genre terres de jean castex non
mais c'est le sexe qui a tenté de
déstabiliser bien sûr genre tu n'es rien
de ça oui bien sûr les élections
régionales pour coûtant calme dans quel
but tout est une réponse à son
intervention par rapport à elle
vous faites cave est entre guillemets un
scandale d'état au niveau des vaccins
est ce que dsk scandale d'état
je laisse les téléspectateurs juger moi
je pense que voilà au lieu de payer
chaque jour chaque semaine des milliards
d'euros je pense qu'on aurait mis un peu
plus sur la table pour acheter des
vaccins comme l'ont fait certains pays
on aurait eu plus de vaccins
donc on aurait pu vacciner plus de
chance mais pour terminer sur cette
région grand est quand vous avez entendu
frédéric bierry sur notre antenne
d'ailleurs demandé dans la foulée un
démembrement de la région grand est est
ce que vous vous êtes inquiet ce que
vous dites il ya peut-être un risque
d'implosion de cette région j'ai
toujours eu un risque depuis le début de
la création de la région je pense que là
le travail est fait il ya même une
réduction de la voilure au niveau des
effectifs de la région une idée vos
dépenses de fonctionnement je pense
qu'il ya un gros travail qui a été fait
et même avant avec le président richert
d'un gros travail de synthèse qui a été
fait donc il faut aller de l'avant
non mais on n'a plus les moyens de se
permettre d'aller un coup en avant un
conte arrière et de faire imploser
quelque chose qui fonctionne
il ya un risque quand même d'implosion
non je pense pas maintenant jean castex
est revenu entre guillemets sur sa
déclaration et le gouvernement a bien
dit que le périmètre resterait tel qu'il
est donc je pense qu'il faut aller de
l'avant
on a terminé en parlant de vous et de
votre mandat avec alec soth sur donc
vous étiez déjà l'un des preuves l'une
de vos premières interventions a porté
sur la loi de programmation de la
recherche en déposant des amendements
qui ont fait grincer le monde
universitaire comment vous avez vécu ce
débat sereinement je pense que j'ai fait
mon travail de parlementaire j'ai déposé
une douzaine d'amendements qui ont été
repris dans le texte dans texte final
avec aussi la collaboration de mes
collègues comme stéphane pied noir au
niveau de l'amendement du c est lui qui
a un peu fait grincer des dents
est ce que vous avez dans le contexte
général le gouvernement abymes a mis 25
milliards d'euros sur la table d'ici
2030 pour financer un enseignement
supérieur pour revaloriser les carrières
à mener différents dispositifs innovants
et ce qui a fait grincer des dents c'est
l'amendement ses nus concernant le
recrutement des universitaires des
professeurs et des maîtres de
conférences à l'université puisque le
nouveau dispositif
qu est ce qui ne sera qu'un test
d'ailleurs ce sera un test dans les
prochains mois assoupli le mode de
recrutement et donne un peu plus de
pouvoir en local plutôt que vous
proposiez un cadre vous dans ce mode de
recrutement et qui était de privilégier
des profils particuliers
oui des profils un peu plus atypique je
pense qu'aussi l'université doit
s'ouvrir
moi j'ai été élu étudiant gsi g dans
toutes les instances universitaires et
ce qui manque vraiment l'université
c'est de s'ouvrir sur le monde du
travail et c'est ce qu'on attend qu'on
fait aussi des études s'est trouvé un
travail assorti de ses études donc il
faut multiplier les stages au fur et à
mesure de son cursus ce qui n'était pas
forcément le cas il ya encore qu'elles
ont le monde universitaire vous accuser
un peu de devoir régler vos comptes
puisque vous aussi vous étiez en thèse
ou n'avait pas terminé est ce que
c'était c'était c'était un peu ça
l'esprit ou non au contraire il ya une
vraie démarche
je vous donne un exemple une collègue
communiste écologie qui a une dizaine
d'années est déposé le même amendement
que moi je pense qu'il ya une volonté de
la part des différentes personnes qui
sont intervenues dans cette loi d'ouvrir
le monde de l'enseignement supérieur et
d'aller de l'avant dernière peut être
fait sans pour cela je suis sûr qu'elle
en pensait oui oui christian poncelet
qui était bon comme on l'a dit ça la
figure tutélaire de les vosges le lui
succéder c'est une charge c'est un poids
mal président est forcément un exemple
pour de nombreux élus dans le
département des vosges c'est vrai qu'il
a fait énormément pour notre département
que ce soit en termes d'infrastructures
mais aussi dans les communes des vosges
beaucoup de maires lui doivent
énormément de projets concrets dans les
différentes communes de notre
département donc c'est un exemple pour
moi et puis pour bien d'autres d'autres
élus les laisser une image positive du
sénat dans les eaux j'ai une image
positive des vosges à paris donc voilà
c'est un conte un travail perpétuel
merci merci beaucoup
l'exemple classique et merci je réglais
merci d'être venu nous voir depuis les
vosges en remercie d'être venu ici à
strasbourg
on va accueillir dans quelques instants
évidemment notre invité jean rottner on
sera avec lui pendant une heure le
président de la région grand-est avant
de recevoir on va regarder son portrait
il a été réalisé par sandra ça plaira
[Musique]